welcome good morning God's a good crowd
today thank you for queuing
thank you for coming and for those who
have not met I'm mark there are some
familiar some familiar faces in the
audience it's great to see people again
as back here at playtime London and it's
great to see a packed house with so many
of you here today ah what's into that a
lot of a lot of what you just saw in the
agenda is about you guys learning and
learning what we've been up to and
learning about what we what we're coming
up with um but I just want to be echo
what Shannon said there is like we'd
like you to be telling us what more
you'd like to be to see and what you'd
like to see happening so you're going to
hear this thing feedback we like we love
feedback in Google so and we love you
guys to take that on board as well
and give us feedback that doesn't
include you Rob I don't need your
feedback today I get enough of that all
the time yeah but it's also we like to
think you have a bit of fun with your
peers with your colleagues intermingle
spend some time we get together and with
them obviously your Google business
partners and what I've been asked to do
apart from Acts is a little bit of a
warm-up act before before the main event
starts le fires after the break that's
when you get all the juicy details of
Android n of material design studio
firebase it's really to talk a little
bit about what's next for Google Play
what we're doing and the things that we
think will happen that will touch your
world and and change some of the change
some of the things you're building over
the next few years um so let's start
with you guys our developers it's your
magic it's your innovation it's your
creativity that brings these
supercomputers few fingers pointing
maybe I've got a couple of it we've got
a couple of your apps up on the screen
but brings brings these computers in our
pockets to life and as Shannon said from
a UK to Estonia it's great to have so
many people here from from age of Lords
Alex this is staring me out to the
Economist - British Airways - candy
crush so such a diverse collection of
apps and games developers here and like
I said the real future of what players
is what you guys build and what you guys
demand from us so we'd love to hear more
about your imagination your stories in
your ideas and
how're your apps are impacting millions
of people and the team thought it would
be kind of fun for me to give a snapshot
of my life and how apps affect my life
so I start I'd start with my kids seeing
is my biggest challenge in my house is
getting my 10 year old boy and my eight
year old daughter off tablets and
smartphones it seemed to be gaining more
and more addicted to them so I don't
whether I'm a great parent or a bad
parent I'll let you guess ask both my
kids to pick their favorite apps
obviously my son is a big fan of
everything that comes out of our friends
at supercell whether it's boom beach
clash Royale is latest and he still
spends a huge amount of time with clash
of clans my daughter's really got into
color switch which those of you have
played it is like right up there with
one of the kiddo obviously it drives me
crazy but her and her friends absolutely
adore this game but I could have listed
crusty road a Gary Oh subway surfer is
another big one in our household and the
other thing that they seem to spend a
huge amount of time is video consumption
um those of you who are into minecraft
my son doesn't really play Minecraft on
the Xbox anymore I just had the echoes
of stampy what you know going around my
house and his kind of high-pitched
squeal of a voice but then they're on
iPlayer now Disney life is out there and
an obvious eats can I go for a football
mad family and they really do dominate
our life and I think as many as you know
kids are probably the biggest and
biggest users of a lot of your a lot of
products and a lot of games are on these
devices but also apps and utilities this
is an example that actually my wife and
I started using house and or below it's
a fantastic app we're about to start
doing some renovation work on our house
and we're a big fan of this this utility
app it really helps you find find an
image of an idea share it and pin it
into a scrapbook and it's just a number
of apps that really change the way you
think I mean some of the great stuff in
here is now they start tagging items in
the images you can actually go on and
look up what is that so for what is that
lamp and leads you through to the
e-commerce site to buy it and a feature
I've not actually used on this is yet
isn't a org mental reality feature where
you can literally pick that so far up
and drop it in sits you to find out
who's going to really look
great in your future lounge um but
there's a hundreds of different apps
that are changing the way people act and
how people behave using their phones I
personally can't imagine ever printing a
boarding pass again or in a major city
phoning for a taxi when I've got lyft or
gets taxi or uber and the great thing is
that millions millions of Android users
have not discovered how much these apps
can change their life so there's so much
more growth ahead of us this was
supposed to be kind of fun
I'd really sing this on the big screen
in rehearsal this morning it's kind of
scary this is me taking a picture
clowning around
on an app called masquerade I'm sure a
lot of you guys have used this this this
has been a great example in my house
just just bringing fun bringing the
magic back into apps if you've not done
has everyone done the face swapping yeah
some people haven't do it it's quite
really fun so a dinner party do the face
whopping and you just see the magic in
people especially if they're not that
familiar what you can do on a phone and
it's just hilarious
obviously video it post it on social
media and scare the hell out of
everybody but these kind of experiences
just bring so much fun into what we do
and what we put put in people's lives
yeah
sorry about the scary clowning around
picture and these guys these guys
probably need a mention because it seems
to be on everyone's everyone's lips at
the moment I mean the great thing about
what an antic and what they've done with
Pokemon go for me I mean I mean it's
obviously it's obviously brought a lot
of people into inter gaming it's brought
a huge amount of people purchasing for
the first time in play which is
obviously fantastic for all of us to add
new paying users but the big thing I
think is a to potential impacts of this
game is it's really brought augmented
reality into the mass market it's taking
it out of hyperbole and this is no
disrespect to the hundreds of apps
developers that have been working really
hard on AR but it's now made there's a
mass-market thing around a format of
obviously spending time walking around
but the other thing that I think is
really interesting about this is it's
it's it's hopefully going to wake up
more triple-eight developers more of
that IP that's been previously just
locked in console and PC to a lot of
your guys benefit but bring these guys
more into mobile and we've seen that and
we tender
Oh square enix and EA they've been early
adopters of mobile but a lot of those
big IP and triple-a them developers have
actually not done as much in terms of
bringing bringing their content onto
mobile hopefully we'll see a lot more of
that on the back of the success of
Pokemon go but that's just my story
that's just a small slice of my story as
you guys know the beauty of what you do
is that there's apps and games for
everyone there's over a staggering 1
million apps on the Play Store now so
it's really huge in terms of the breadth
and the depth and the message just to
finish this bit is that it's what you
guys do is that's what drives us and we
love the passion that you have the
creativity you have an imagination that
drives us on and very much what's next
for Google Play is what you guys imagine
and create um so let's to cover a little
bit of what we do to help you guys some
of you guys know this well um if you
don't know this our mission is really to
help you guys succeed and grow global
businesses every Googler that's here
today with a with a blue tag on is here
to help you I'm not going to stress the
feedback thing again but they they want
to make your business bigger and and
you're going to hear a lot on both the
apps and the game sections today about
how you can be more successful on Play
the biggest thing is the platform that
we've created play and Android is now
the largest app distribution platform in
the world and I'll talk in the next few
slides around some of the numbers that
make up Android and play and what what
why we're so proud of the success and
scale that we have and second one is we
provide tools to improve your
performance whether it's with deep
around lytx a be testing beta release
programs you're gonna hear a lot more
about this today from the speakers in
the following sessions and the breakout
sessions and as any's going to talk
about the new features you're going to
see in Android n in Android studio in
firebase and in material design there's
a lot of stuff here for you to pick up
today to try and soak up as much as you
can and yeah try and stay off the Wi-Fi
try not to get distracted and try and
learn and um and give us feedback on
what you say
and finally as a partner and a lot of
what we do and you'll see sessions today
is about supporting vertical supporting
groups of you as our developers whether
it's publishing whether it's indie games
where's the media sector which families
and shadows got a session later on today
again on families it's helping these
categories succeed within play and
creating quite unique experiences to
bring the best out of the content you
have in those categories and that
partnership again is critical we want
that feedback
tell us what more things we could be
doing whether it's a reaction to a first
impression of something you've seen
today or a deep bugbear that's been
ticking away in your engineering team
for a long while please come to us tell
us what you think and help us be a
better partner for you and so let's talk
about distribution the good news is
Android continues to grow at a
staggering rate they're the biggest
smartphone platform in the world with
over 1.4 billion monthly users and
that's growing every week is more and
more people get connected and get a
smartphone for the first time as that
technology gets cheaper as it gets more
accessible we're going to see more and
more people cars reading the Horowitz
blog yesterday and and they said that by
2020 80 percent of the world's adult
population will have an internet
internet connected smartphone now
forecast the forecast but the the basic
trend and momentum is that the majority
this this planets population are going
to have access to the Internet and going
to have access to very cheap affordable
computing and the great news for ours is
the vast proportion of those users are
going to be on Android so that 1.5
million a day new Android devices is
only going to accelerate and only going
to give you a bigger audience to build
and take your products to and also the
ecosystem is getting bigger we're not
going to talk a lot about the expansion
of the ecosystem today but we have a
fantastic team working hard to add more
oh em gee that ecosystem and to bring
more carriers on board and we now have
over 500 carriers working working with
Android and working with play and 400 oh
mmm
developing for Android and as is
ecosystem expand is great news for play
the result is more Android users are
coming in to the Play Store they're
finding apps are down
and more and more of them are spending
we now have over a billion monthly users
who have downloaded a staggering 65
billion apps just in the last year alone
so the engagement is huge and our work
really has gone into enabling more of
these customers to actually spend money
on play and we do a lot of work adding
local forms of payment finding ways for
consumers particularly in emerging
markets to make that first purchase to
educate them away they can actually have
a better experience if they spend but
also to give them access to local forms
of payments one of those most important
forms of payments is what we call DCB
that's direct carrier billing so that's
paying through your mobile phone bill
and in emerging markets where gift card
penetration is lower or credit and
credit cards
and not really relevant for a lot of
people DCB is incredibly important and
we now have a hundred deals live in over
41 markets and actually 100 steel was a
point of quite good contention within
our business development teams the APAC
team was saying it was a carrier called
idea in India the AMIA team were
claiming that the hundreds deal signed
was Vodafone in a mere hey they're great
challenges have that actually Vodafone
went live first as a deal but I think
they're two great examples idea is one
of the biggest carriers in India over
190 million subscribers as a significant
proportion on Android and obviously
growing is more more of those customers
dot smartphones and voter we're all
familiar with its thumb is the biggest
biggest carrier in the mirror and
actually means we've got 100% coverage
in most of our markets in the mirror now
on DCB so great to have both those deals
now on board and and have such a strong
payment platform with our carrier
partners and the good news is that this
is now starting to actually see a
meaningful effect particularly in those
merging markets now we'd expect these
growth rates to be huge because we're
starting from a low base but we're
seeing download downloads absolute
downloads for four times the level we're
seeing in mature markets that the
consumption is huge driven by an
expanding platform as more and more
people get smartphones but it's also
demand people want to be entertained on
these devices it opens up a whole world
that they've not
to experience before and as I talked
about in payments on the back about our
job is to actually enable more these
people to spend and we're seeing a very
fast twice twice that twice as down the
pace of firms spend growth in emerging
markets than we're seeing in mature
markets as users make their first
payment and then become habitual users
in terms of spending what disposable
income they have on your product it's
very exciting so doing all this we're
doing some work to globally to expand
the platform and we're working hard to
help you guys find your audience and
play with it and we hear this a lot I
mean yeah we've done work around beta
testing and and allowing you to do stage
manage roll rollouts but we've got great
feedback from you not just a playtime
but through the year about what we can
do to make it easier for you to recruit
beta testers often you guys are their
friends or family they're people using
that before but finding complete newbies
that give back to the great beta tester
has proved to be hard so we launched a
collection called the early access
program just over a month ago just after
i/o with 29 apps to start off with and
and we've had over a million installs
since iron what we did we basically
opened up this collection to those users
that had a very high propensity to
engage with apps and games early on so
they were just inquisitive they'd like
to try things and we felt this was a
really great audience to open up to to
you to to developers and the great news
is that we're expanding the program
outside of the startups and then is we
had to all developers so if you want to
learn more about this and you want to
learn more about this is that please
come to the launch smart amp session
today or talk to them your your BD
manager today and they can give you more
information how you can get into this
early access program another thing I
just wanted to highlight is how you
drive acquisition and for those of you
have a user acquisition budget and
marketing budget you know app discovery
is a critical role in driving your
growth and driving your user base but we
wanted to leverage our experience in ads
as well within within the store and
search as in play launched over a year
ago and we've seen significant
says with search ads in play and then
the developers I see spending on this
channel I consistently get feedback
there's great CPI's this is a really
efficient channel and they're using it
as part of their marketing budget to
find both high quality users and users
with intent and unit search is a really
critical part of that discovery process
within the store and you can do search
in a couple of ways you can buy search
campaign that we run across comm and
search within play you can't buy a
campaign just on on play search but you
can also purchase within a universal app
campaign which drives acquisition across
YouTube across go and Google search
engine Google comm and other Google
properties as well including AdMob so
advertising within within other apps
universal app campaigns alone who've
driven three billion app installs so I
implore you guys to try it and to
explore it and to give it a go we're
investing heavily in helping you acquire
more users and so I'm you see some more
announcements over the coming months
about changes we're doing this and if
you'd like to learn more about universal
app campaigns there's a session after
lunch so trees try and join that as well
um so to summarize the first bit this is
this is this is my asks this is it this
is as bad as it gets take it you can
take a picture the slides these are the
basics these are the things that we want
to see all you guys doing they're pretty
straightforward and we continue to
repeat the focus on quality I'm ask you
there is like quality is king we create
a lot of tools to try and allow you to
get your product better and better
please don't listen to our feedback we
apply a lot of resource in our teams to
try and give you that consulting that
feedback of how you can improve your
products so focus on design make it easy
to use really invest in quality if the
products not right work on it until
you've got that right and the iteration
piece and follows really back and fast
on that on the heels of this we've
created many tools to help to do
experiments that lead to direct
performance improvements and we've been
speaking to top developers about how
many they use a/b testing or staged
rollouts or store listing experiments
and 70%
top developers say they use this
functionality and it absolutely helps
them get their product better
60% of top developers use beta testing
my question is what the rest not why the
rest not doing this if this
functionality is really going to help
you guys have better product as no
coding is free it's easy to use why
white wine all your team's using these
tools that we build please please take
take take a chance to learn more about
the tools today again there's a session
at the launch smart session about how
you can use our tools to iterate and get
that product right before you spend
precious user acquisition but on budget
and find that as a retention issue that
you'd not spotted before try search ads
I've just talked about on the previous
slide but next time you sit down with
user acquisition team go through and ask
whether you spent any money on search
within play or universal app campaigns
and see what the performance numbers
look like developer console we'll talk
about that later on today it's a great
tool not just for your engineering teams
but also for your marketeers and and the
the non engineering folk within your
teams um it's a a great plan a great way
for you to find what's going on with
your user base the analytics at what
your conversion funnel is looking like
so again try and use that and also we
have our playbook app with a host of
articles and information in there and
please try it I think I've mentioned the
feedback one at the end as well ok
that's that's the asks over as the
temperature rises the tissue loves to
find a venue with glass ceilings I think
the I think playtime has to be in a kind
of warehouse or garage with glass
ceilings in London so apologies to those
guys over there that were really under
the cosh and it's like I oh isn't it you
know I always outdoors and very hot and
we like to replicate that here and play
time the last section we talk about is
briefly about the future and about the
future of mobile and you've seen this
picture before you've probably seen this
like 20 times just on the way here today
you know face down touch and swipe you
know great products but designed for
that form of interaction people download
apps from top charts or search and we
buy an entire ecosystem a very
successful ecosystem about this type of
user behavior and about this type of
interaction within hours
door um but we really think that mobile
is evolving and we think it's evolving a
number of different ways that will be a
new era for mobile beyond this kind of
mobile first and touch and swipe era and
I wanted to talk about three areas
beyond the click beyond the install and
also beyond the phone and just talk
about some of the investments Google and
making in these areas that we think will
massively change your perspective and
what you can do within your products in
the near future
and in the mid term future as well so
beyond the click the phone start with a
touch screen you can tap swipe
revolutionary everyone's like this
changes the whole way I'm using a mobile
phone it'd never be the same this is the
future I can't believe I couldn't
actually touch and interact on a device
it makes things so much better but but
new new elements of input are now
becoming very very strong and will soon
be mass-market voice is the first one we
wanted to highlight a staggering 40% of
Android and Google Google Android app
searches are now using voice and that's
driven by huge advances in natural
language processing that's helping us
and understand the spoken word far
better than we've ever done before to a
much higher high degree and Google's
actually training its models to ignore
background noise so it's easy easier to
hear what the individual is saying to
the phone and so I mean I still amazed
people when I do in ok Google with
friends and family are still sleeping I
had watch what's going on it's like yeah
I genuinely think a bit like with
autonomous cars in 10 15 years or maybe
five years of the rate of speed
autonomous driving is going people look
back and say what you really drove a car
but did like millions of people died
yeah diverse cars are much better than
yeah and I think voice I mean people
look back and say why were you typing
why were you just speaking to your
computers all the time and and devices
like Google home which was announced at
i/o and there's a few other kind of home
speakers that you can interact with a
voice a really going to make that that
level of interaction in the mainstream
so I think we will look back and see you
know typing is a thing of the past and
voice is one of the main inputs for a
lot of the Apple experiences you're
building
gesture is another huge area that's
coming and one of my favorite projects
if you saw it at i/o it's a project
called project soli s oli and that was
announced from Google's atap team that's
advanced technologies and platforms team
this is really cool this is um this is
just a gift to showing the gesture
control but have a look at the video
from IO what it basically uses but short
wave radio frequencies comment like
radar to to actually have a detailed
understanding of how how your hand is
moving and then you can start to
actually make changes and swipe and
interact with your device and it's very
it's already very sophisticated even
though it's in a very early stage of the
product and it kind of reminds me might
like Minority Report no no one gets that
I'm showing my age yeah or maybe maybe
Tony Stark from my man for the younger
devs here that don't know what minority
boys but yeah that kind of proper
interaction and a completely new way of
interacting with an app or even with a
game and and and it won't replace I
think this will complement voice it will
complement touch but it you know that
third dimension of gesture control will
bring a new experience to products and I
think the solid that solid dev kit for
hardware manufacturers doesn't go live
to next year so this one really is you
know one a year or two out but I mean
you can start to think of great things
and applications you could do around is
I personally I just want to get this one
in that I'd love to see an out where I
could just play the piano on top of my
phone so if someone could pick that one
up or it does anyone know the Hungry
Hippos game so I could just bash it I
couldn't no okay I'll leave the
creatives here to you guys but there's a
great there's a great you know world of
magic an actually bring out there with
this gesture control in the app another
one is conversational UI if you follow
dire you will see the announcement of a
low which has not been in release yet
but this is bringing box into Google's
new messaging platform and combining a
low combines you know AI with um search
assistance and the interesting thing for
you guys is how we bring developers and
particular app developers into this
experience
and this is a huge area for google in
technology for everyone
assistant bringing AI into more and more
of our products and a big theme for play
and our team was how we can bring you
into these experiences and maybe even
bring AI into into your businesses as
well so voice gesture conversational UI
these are just three ways that we think
that the interface of how people
interact with your products is going to
change over the next few years and now
let's look beyond the app and beyond the
install as well a lot of you a bit
brilliant brilliant native experiences
brilliant experiences to mobile and but
one thing we I think we all agree on is
it would be great to bring new users to
your products even quicker and still
there's some hurdles for that install
experience some speed bumps and some
access issues that actually just don't
exist on the web and particularly for
people in the first time and and that
the product team in play we're just
thinking wouldn't be great if you could
have that same beautiful experience on
the web just tap and then you're there
and and then a few the guys are here
today and started imagining how we can
actually bring this to life and and I'm
sure many of you saw this this
announcement at i/o I'm hoping you have
I'm assuming you have them I'm certainly
not going to try and do what Ellie
powers and the team did so well on stage
at i/o and talk to you this product but
but for those who aren't familiar with
instant apps please spend a bit of time
on this what it what it is is
effectively exactly what it says on the
tin you can run an Android app
instantaneously which makes it much
easier for users to discover to share
and enjoy your products this example
here was an example using and B&H which
is a massive camera retailer in the
States and we have a great app but the
example is very pertinent because
obviously a lot of people don't really
search for camera week-in week-out so a
lot of people might not have and the bnh
app installed on their phone but as you
can see here someone's gone through a
search experience they've clicked on
that search and what it's done is it's
just gone straight into the page within
the app that uses interested in this
demo is this app is not pre-installed on
the device
and then actually within that incident
experience they can then add that
product if they want to the basket pay
with Android pay and check out and
without entering any additional
information and we and I'm you know a
lot of people who speak to think this
kind of experience is incredibly
incredibly cool no visit to the Play
Store no accepting permissions no
waiting for a download no having to type
in again the same search results for
that camera within that app you straight
there you're able to purchase it's a
fantastic experience and really what it
means it's a much faster is it's a much
more seamless experience and getting
that deep link right into the right page
of the app what the two have done is
they've broken the apps into separate
modules so make it a lot lighter for
those modules actually to be consumed
and installed on the product and then
that instant flow of the app is
optimized for the device and there's a
lot of work going to make this backwards
compatible a long way backwards
compatible to reduce that friction and
allow instant apps on a lot of previous
versions of Android and another element
of this and this is again another demo
that I've just lifted out by oh it's
really around and it's around a BuzzFeed
video it's about how to make content
that exists in your app really
accessible again the web is very easy I
can share a link someone's on the web
page is great but often that's very hard
to do within the app that changes with
instant apps because as you can see here
so I'm gonna share the link to a cooking
video on BuzzFeed that on an SMS with a
tap that opens instance instantly within
the BuzzFeed app which remember it's not
pre-installed on the user's device and
and then they can access that content so
this this opens up a whole new set of
opportunities for you guys to really
compete with like a web presence you
don't need to have a web presence and
try new marketing techniques and try new
ways to get people and customers to
engage with your products and and then
if people want to keep the app on their
device then you can you can prop them to
in store and they can keep it keep it
fixed in and this is a real-world
example I don't have ficus here to
present with a with a with a pay meter
like they had at i/o but this is a real
word example that but has bugged me
multiple times
epic our pilot last night is a snow dome
in Milton Keynes kids desperate to get
in there and I've got a choice fine a
premium rate number and and or download
an app and clearly it's a horrendous
experience if you could just literally
rock up to that to that sign in the
carpark tap on the meter NF it NFC could
instantly launching it's an app on your
device you can instantly pay it's really
seamless it's really easy it's really
simple it's just cool and and I think
you know this is a real-world problem
well you know first world real world
problem better real world problem for a
few there's any how I'm sure lot of you
excited about it a few by-product leads
are here micros whiskey Jonathan caramel
and where they are they're hiding at the
back of it as a hand up there I mean if
you guys done it just aggressively
pursue them around the event today
they've got a lot of meetings booked in
but if you can't get hold of them speak
to your Android BD manager they will
make sure that you get connected about
this we are in a very small early access
program the momentum on this project is
huge they're moving a really great piece
pace so so please please learn more
about it it could be a really huge
paradigm shift in terms of the at
consumption model and and crucially
really help you reduce that friction of
how people consume your app right
and then finally be on the phone how am
i doing I've got five minutes it's great
because it's all about virtual reality
neck so I can make that one up the
ecosystem is expanding from wearables to
car to TV there's still a huge amount of
investment going into taking that
Android ecosystem to more devices for
those of you that building experience
that consumed on different form factors
there's a there's a lot more coming I
talked about that ecosystem of four
hundred OEMs working on Android which is
getting bigger and bigger all the time
we also wanted to announce them and you
might see this i/o placed doors also on
Chromebooks and Chromebooks have been
hugely successful particularly in North
America
IDC just announced that in 2016 for q2
20 2016 Chromebooks the number one spot
in the u.s. out starting out signing max
and the great news is now the Play Store
is available on these devices so you
be able to offer your Android apps to
millions of users on Chromebooks as well
without any additional work without
sacrificing any performance so it's a
kind of nice one is it's you know the
world has changed and rather than web to
mobile now we're over mobile straight
back to laptops the other way around
so we think that's fantastic and again
opens up an exposure for you and then
finally I just want to touch on VR
because everyone's talking about it and
clearly it's a big part of our future
and our future on mobile
they are like AR it's now kind of
getting to be a truly immersive
comfortable and and affordable
experience this is about the future in
fortune we don't have anything on AR to
show you today there's no day dream demo
in the breakout session I'm afraid I
have personally done it quite a few
times it is awesome
it's not going to make you feel any
better because you have played let's say
played around with daydream but it was
it was announced at i/o for built on on
the Android M platform and we're
currently working with our first
partners to to prepare this for launch
and and we do intend to make this
available for you guys as soon as
possible I mean I mean our goal with VR
and with daydream is to make it as
accessible to as many people as possible
and in many respects it builds on the
work that we've done around cardboard in
cardboard
I think there's brought VR to over five
million people and we've had over 50
million installs of cardboard ABS so
that's a great start and that's a great
foundation to build on for the day dream
team but what they've done is they've
gone into a whole new level of bringing
the software together with the hardware
to create a premium VR experience and
and that means working very closely with
a whole host of Android manufacturers
with hardware manufacturers around
upcoming phones and sharing designs for
the VR viewer product and and also the
controller that makes it such an
immersive and exciting experience and
but that's not going to work without
without your apps this is just a screen
grab of what the Play Store will look
like in virtual reality we're kind of
creating this welcoming space where
people can hang out and explore the top
row is something called discovery
windows where you
where you will be able to promote your
best your best content and users can
preview the experience in VR and next
I'd like to show you a very quick video
of how developers will be able to use
the controller which is which is
actually incredible for this as well
and is that it's that controller that I
personally I think a lot of people are
incredibly excited about I mean the
potential you can turn it you know it's
a tennis racket a whisk
you saw the pancake I've done the
pancake flipping really and really good
at it actually because it happens but
you can just play around it move around
it lots of different ways the Rob was
laughing at that gag we got the same
terrible sense humor but you know when
you start to see this thing you're just
going to your minds gonna be open to a
whole load of opportunities you can do
Ram VR and around your gameplay that
will literally transform the experience
for users of your products and your IP
and it's not just about game developers
that we have a lot of content owners
here today one of the best experience
I've seen that as I've watched a 3d
movie in a 3d cinema on the VR headset I
mean I immediately I'm thinking anyone
on a plane is going to have one of these
things on because it's so much better
you literally feel like you're watching
something at IMAX experience and it's
incredible for such for such a you know
to put your headset on having that
experience and turning around and seeing
people next to you or having a cinema on
your own it's really cool in companies
like Wall Street Journal HBO Netflix and
be able committed to adding VR to the
platform so content is really important
when you're bringing a new technology to
market so that's it that's it that's
that's the future Google Play I'm out of
time I'm cutting I'm going people that
do not caring a little bit longer no I'm
going to really annoy you talked about
feedback and it talked about having fun
get in the ring
I mean thing is it's such a cool cut a
cool day today and the temperatures not
too high we've got some really thick
sumo outfits that you can go and put on
and just to raise your temperature a
little bit more
I'd suggest you challenge your BD
manager to sumo fight this afternoon
usually it may be after a couple of
mojitos or something
Lilly's going to challenge me to a fight
in a second there's a feedback form you
have if you fill in that form you can
get stamped for it to be doing
activities today you'll get a little
surprise just to manage the expectations
it's a little surprise it's not like a
VR headset or a car or anything like
that
maybe there's a prize there don't know
but yeah please fill in please enjoy the
day it's great to have so many of you
here
it's great to get playtime back it's
great that the team is doing such an
amazing job with a venue again so please
enjoy it I'd love to talk to as many of
you as possible today and thank you very
much for coming thanks
you